Hey, David.
On balance.
Do you think that the protests help or hurt
Donald Trump?
I think that they hurt him.
I believe that early the idea that Trump had
was that they would help.
I just think he miscalculated.
There is no question that when you see protests,
some small portion of which end up having
some.
Violent elements and arrests taking place,
arson, looting, etc..
Certainly Trump's base is activated.
They are motivated.
They become more enthusiastic about voting
for Donald Trump.
I don't deny that.
The problem is I think that the protests are
really hurting Trump with everybody who is
not already committed to him.
And if you only are pleasing the people already
voting for you, you can't make up a three,
five, seven or nine point popular vote deficit,
which is what different polls claim.
Donald Trump is currently experiencing.
Most people aren't falling for.
If you see a violent confrontation in Portland,
that's what you will have under Joe Biden's
America.
Most people aren't falling for that.
Most people are accurately recognizing.
Wait a second.
Biden's America trumps president right now.
This is happening in Trump's America right
now.
And it reminds me a little bit of the situation
when Donald Trump was asked about early in
Corona virus, earlier in Corona virus.
Do you take responsibility for this or that?
And Trump said, I take no responsibility at
all.
Apply that logic to the protests and to the
elements of the protests that have been violent,
which, again, is very, very small.
And Trump actually spotlights those incidents,
thinking it will hurt Joe Biden.
And he says it's Biden's fault that this is
happening.
It's radical Marxists fault that this is happening.
And it will be even worse if they win.
It's backfiring because it doesn't pass the
sniff test.
And what this ultimately gets back to is that
Donald Trump was a much stronger candidate,
running as an insurgent who had not had a
career in politics and who could sort of credibly
criticize whoever is running and whoever is
in power.
Trump's been president now for four years,
and yet he's still trying to run like an insurgent.
Trump is still saying, you've got to reelect
me so I can do the wall and do health care
and do more taxes and all of this other stuff.
He's been president for four years, and it's
a gambit that I believe has failed him.
He may still win for other reasons, but I
think continuing to run as an outsider, even
though he's been president now for four years,
I think it's a mistake.
And if you look at the polling data, you see
it when the unrest happened in Wisconsin.
There were people saying this is going to
hurt Joe Biden and it's going to hurt Democrats.
You had enlightened, centrist grifter's, right.
Saying Trump just won.
The Senate is going to stay Republican because
of what's going on in Wisconsin.
A lot of pundits jumped all over that, not
pun dense, as some say, pundits.
Come on, we know the word p0 NDIC.
And in fact, Joe Biden is polling slightly
better today in Wisconsin than he was when
Jacob Blache got shot.
It's marginal.
It's a small it's a small delta.
But things have not gotten worse for Joe Biden
in Wisconsin since that happened.
And I think that what's happening are two
different things.
One, most people aren't buying that what we're
seeing has anything to do with Joe Biden.
It's happening under Donald Trump and Trump's
actions have actually worsened it.
When Trump sent federal agents like jack booted
thugs to areas with unrest to carry out, you
know, authoritarian Soviet style tactics,
throwing people into vans and all of this
stuff, he could have instead used the bully
pulpit to say we are demanding federal investigations
of the police officers and departments involved.
This is not what the next four years are going
to look like in America.
He could have listened to people on systemic
race it.
Right.
He could have done it differently.
And I think he'd be cruising to reelection
if he had done that and paid more attention
to the virus for sure.
But instead, he didn't do that.
And it it has made it it has fomented the
feeling that things are unstable and instability
tends not to be good for the incumbent.
So that's my bottom line.
I think that Donald Trump's base is certainly
enthusiastically going to vote for Trump because
of the protests, but they were going to vote
for Trump anyway.
Maybe they're just doing it slightly more
enthusiastically.
I think with everybody else, the protests
have been very, very bad for Donald Trump.